من جديد نذكر
بالخبر العجل الذي هو موضوع تغطيتنا
المستمره حيث اصيب خمسه اسرائيليين جرائد
اطلاق نار على مقهى في شارع
وسطات تل ابيب اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
قالت انه تم قتل مطلق النار ويجري التحقق
مما اذا كان هناك شخص اخر في المنطقه
وقالت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي ان اثنين من
المصابين في حاله خطره واضافت ان رئيس
الحكومه بنيامينه نياهو يبحث تقديم موعد
عودته من روما في اعقاب عمليه اطلاق النار
التي وصفها بانها عمليه صعبه وارهابيه
وقال رئيس بلديه تل ابيب ان عمليه اطلاق
النار وسط المدينه خلفيتها قوميه وطالب
الاسرائيليين بوقت الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
فورا عقب هذه العمليه
ويعتبر شارع حيث جرت العمليه احد اكثر
الشوارع اكتظاظا في تل ابيب
وقد اظهرت لقطات بثت على الانترنت صوت
طلقات ناريه في العمليه التي خلفت خمسه
اصابات
وقتل فيها منفذ العمل
[تصفيق]